marginalized communities all of these
things will help our communities keep
their water
safe and clean something i'm
particularly proud of
is how this bill provides flexibility to
both
rural and urban areas and let them
decide how to investigate their needs
the most significant investments in this
bill are in the drinking water and clean
water
state revolving funds as we know them
srf's
the srfs maximize authority for the
states
to determine how best to address
drinking and wastewater challenges
utilizing a revolving loan fund to
facilitate
additional future investments for rural
states like west virginia we offer
several solutions to unique water
challenges
i will add here we have a little rate
walk in west virginia
first the bill invests 50 billion
dollars
for those currently being served by
intractable water systems
those are the systems that service fewer
than a thousand people
and that have typically been abandoned
by the operator
we have quite a few of those towns in
the southern coal fields of west
virginia like those in mcdowell county
have historically struggled with this
since many of these households cannot
connect to municipal water systems
in an economic or technologically
feasible way
the funding will go to a grant program
to help them install in vital
environmentally sound decentralized
wastewater systems
this language is something that i worked
on previously with my colleague from new
jersey cory booker when he was on the
committee in the last congress
the most pressing water issue from a
human health
and environmental perspective in
appalachia is undoubtedly straight
piping
this practice is common in other
exceptionally rural
and remote areas around the country so
with new septic tanks installed
the grant program is working to improve
quality of life
and addresses public health and
environmental concerns about straight
piping waste into rivers and streams
infrastructure resiliency and
sustainability is also a priority
in the spill in rural areas especially
some of the pipes are nearly 100 years
old
i've actually heard about wooden wooden
pipes small
towns often don't have the revenues to
spend on expensive drinking water and
wastewater
infrastructure upgrades that's why this
legislation creates grants for small
public water systems
to replace components to identify and
prevent
leaks and to install meters
this is based off of language i
introduced last congress
in the assuring quality water
infrastructure act
i was joined there by my colleague ben
cardin of maryland
to address the needs of small water
systems that are being
faced are facing operational challenges
in maintaining drinking water services
we have them every state has them in
west virginia that is often the result
of old infrastructure or the lack of
adequate mapping of where these
assets actually exist
it is hard to fix leaks when you can't
find them
reports have shown this stunned me when
i saw this reports have shown that only
one quarter of the water that west
virginia
water systems pay to have treated and
pumped
even reaches a faucet one quarter that's
how much
water leaks out and i think about my
other states
who have water shortages and here we are
wasting so much water
in a state like ours who has an
abundance of water water is a precious
resource and wasting that much of it
because of leaky pipes and faulty
infrastructure
is absolutely unacceptable the 250
million dollar grant program will help
provide the technical assistance
instruct
investments these small systems serving
10 000 people or fewer
need to address to get those challenges
off their back
and to get on sure fiscal footing
for the uh as they better serve their
customers
of course we don't want to forget about
our mid-size and large
drinking water systems another program
that i worked on
uh last congress again with senator
cardin
addresses the resiliency of drinking
water and wastewater systems
adapted by the clean infrastructure
resilience and sustainability act these
programs totaling 370 million
over five years will help protect public
water systems
from a host of threats both natural
and man-made in west virginia and many
other parts of the country the greatest
threats to drinking and wastewater
infrastructure
comes from flooding these investments
will harden
infrastructure against these threats to
protect taxpayers
from paying for the same infrastructure
again and again
i just discussed physical resilience but
we must also ensure the resilience of
our water utility workforce
those workers who ensure the continued
operation and maintenance of drinking
water and waste
water systems every day section 211 of
dawia focuses on the resilience
of america's water utility workforce
by addressing recruitment training
and retention challenges this is a topic
very important with me
and i worked again with my colleague
from new jersey senator booker on this
issue
i cannot help but think that we
regularly take for granted the public
service
public health services provided by this
nation's water utility workforce
just don't really think about who's
actually the
working there and providing the service
that we
sometimes take for granted unfortunately
a large portion of the men and women who
are in our water treatment facilities
are getting older and they're retiring
and that's why we need to make sure that
we have the next generation of water
workers ready
this bill increases fund rise to 25
million
or five years a program that helps water
systems
grow their workforce through
apprenticeships through training
programs
and it also helps with their retention
efforts this program has been extremely
popular
with water systems around the country
and congress has
recognized this by funding it beyond the
authorization level it is critical that
we provide the tools and investments
necessary
to help our drinking water and waste
water systems face these changes
on after all this is the workforce that
will ensure
the operation and maintenance of all the
other infrastructure investments
this package creates additional
technical assistance can also help
systems with operations it's much more
complicated
than what it used to be and prevent
outages and costly compliance issues
section 206 establishes and authorizes
a circuit rider program designed to help
owners and operators of small and
medium-sized
publicly owned treatment works we've
heard from the water community that
other circuit
rider programs have been a tremendous
asset
in providing technical assistance it
only makes sense for the epa
to similarly provide technical
assistance
since they implement the relevant
regulations
this can be tremendously helpful where a
system may be struggling with an
insufficient workforce
and also must be a part of the
resilience discussion
another concern for us was the alarming
trend in cyber security threats
in water systems in february
you all might remember hackers accessed
a florida water
treatment facility computer system and
were able to remotely
raise the level of sodium sodium
hydroxide
in the water i mean that is not just
scary it's
alarming this has huge national security
implications
on top of the obvious public health
concerns
thankfully that hack was detected and
the system was returned to normal before
the public was ever
at risk but in this day and age water
infrastructure resiliency also has to
include
addressing these cyber security issues
so
we made sure that these vulnerabilities
could be addressed under resiliency
grants
while water infrastructure investments
are critical to ensuring we're not
wasting water
and our water is clean it is also
critical to the economic develop from an
economic development perspective
berkeley county close here close here to
washington d.c
in west virginia made huge investments
into their water infrastructure system
to ensure the system could handle the
volume
of water that the brand new
procter and gamble plant needed and it's
massive amounts of water and it's a
massive plants
and we're very happy they're there
employing
over a thousand west virginians so with
that upgraded water system
pg was able to operate more efficiently
and even to expand
and they're still expanding and that
meant more jobs
that kind of opportunity needs to be
available everywhere
not just in my home state connecticut
and other places around the country
these are just a few of the provisions
that that address
and are informed by the particular
challenges
that face my state but based on the
feedback of my colleagues in both
parties
and the groundswell of support for
various what from various water advocacy
groups
it is clear these provisions have broad
applicability to help communities all
across
this beautiful country it is why we have
a
such a diverse and growing coalition of
more than 70 supporters
from all from water systems to local
governments
to industry to labor to environmental
organizations who are supporting this
legislation
these organized in these organizations
not to mention we had a unanimous vote
out of a committee
these organizations recognize the value
of this legislation and its common sense
and responsible approach
to addressing our water infrastructure
issues
we will be discussing more valuable
provisions of this
on the senate floor this week and i look
forward to that debate
in closing i just want to urge my
colleagues to vote
in the favor in favor of advancing this
bill and later for
final passage i mentioned it passed
unanimously
out of committee there's a big debate in
the in the in a broader sense
can congress get together on
infrastructure this
is what i would define as basic core
infrastructure
this i think is a good test case for us
uh and this i think
uh is one in which we all have a great
interest
conservatives moderates and liberals all
came together on this
i'd like to thank my counterpart my
chairman chairman carper
and his staff for their work as well as
our water subcommittee
counterpart chairman chairman duckworth
and ranking member
lummus this bill is proof that we can
work together on infrastructure this is
a bipartisan
responsible meaningful investment we're
taking care of pipes
we're looking out for our environment
and we're putting special emphasis
on helping rural and disadvantaged
communities
at the end of the day this bill is
really about helping people
this is a bipartisan bill that we can
all be proud of
i again ask my colleagues to vote yes on
the motion to proceed
and again on the underlying bill and i
yield the floor and thank you mr
president
[Music]
this
okay
[Music]
[Music]
now
ah
there
mr president the senator from
alaska mr president i said the quorum
call be initiated
we uh we we are in a quorum call right
now
we are not in a quote unquote the
senator is recognized
mr president i ask unanimous consent to
be able to complete my remarks
uh given time restraints without
rejection
mr president i rise today to oppose
colin calls nomination for under
secretary of defense for policy
and i advise my colleagues to do the
same as we are getting ready to take a
vote
on this very important position
in the pentagon uh
that to me is one of the most important
positions we have
at the department of defense while i
have many policy disagreements with dr
call which i've discussed at length with
him
i want to say i have a long history of
working
across the aisle democrats and
republicans
on defense issues even with those
uh who i don't agree with their policies
on matter of fact the presiding officer
and i
have a very strong working relationship
and we don't agree on a lot of
issues but particularly on issues of the
military i serve on the armed services
committee
i take these matters very seriously
they're one of the main reasons i ran
for the u.s senate
six and a half years ago and i
focus a lot on the military personnel
uniform and civilian that we put
in pentagon that have this enormous
responsibility to oversee
the department of defense and whether
it's assistant secretaries
under secretaries admirals generals
i try to understand where they're coming
from
and i have a record of strongly
supporting
almost all of them whether in the obama
administration
the trump administration and even
in the biden administration for example
i not only supported the secretary of
defense
lloyd austin knowing that i wasn't going
to agree with him on everything i
actually introduced him at his
confirmation hearing because i served
with him in the military
a number of years ago and i know he's a
man
of honor and character
i strongly supported the deputy
secretary of defense kath hicks
given her background and knowledge
but some nominees i have not and i will
not support
particularly in this area that's so
important to our nation's defense
i will object to these people because
like dr
call i don't believe he has the
temperament or judgment to do the job
and like i said mr president i have
looked
at and focused on dozens and dozens of
members
who need senate confirmation in the
department of defense
their temperament and judgment the vast
vast majority
democrat or republican i've supported
but not this one and this is a really
important position
the under secretary of defense for
policy is essentially the number three
position
in the pentagon and as i mentioned it's
my view
and i believe most of my colleagues view
at least on this side of the outlet dr
kaul does not have the temperament
or judgment and i've in fact i believe
that he has potential to be a liability
to our national security and our defense
and not to be viewed favorably favorably
by the men and women
he is supposed to lead
let me talk about temperament mr
president
and a little bit of background not even
a year ago
a number of senate democrats my
colleagues
wrote the official who was nominated by
the trump administration
for this same position under secretary
defense for
policy brigadier general anthony tata
and the letter which was signed by a
number of my senate democrat colleagues
many of whom are on the armed services
committee
focused on that nominee's record
of quote offensive and inflammatory
comments
which would disqualify you from serving
in your current position
in the position for which you have been
nominated that's one of the quotes
remember same position trump
administration
this letter also said
that he had made inflammatory remarks
regarding
the president that would be president
obama
and inflammatory remarks
regarding rhetoric for members of
congress as well
again that was last year this is the
standard that was being used
this letter goes on to say your multiple
past statements cannot be dismissed as
that as simple an aberration
so i mentioned this letter mr president
and i'd like to submit it for the record
without objection so ordered because
you have almost the identical situation
here what happened with general tata
tata is it his nomination
for a lot of these reasons was withdrawn
by the trump administration
but now when you have the same almost
identical issues with this nominee when
i've showed this letter to my
democratic colleagues they're like oh no
that's that's okay
it's not okay it's not okay so let's
talk
about temperament
tweets dr call
has been really the issue here is
is he more of a political hack who's
tweeting all the time
he tweets quite a lot or
in somebody with the temperament of a
partisan internet troll
or is he a measured national security
professional who can lead the pentagon
in the number three position
unfortunately i think it's the former
issue not the latter
he's got a long history of tweets and
just like the issues that my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle objected
to last year for the same position
it's good perfect